we have seen what absolute value of a
number means what is the absolute value
of minus three it tells us the distance
of minus three from zero on a number
line as minus three is three units away
from zero its absolute value will be
three and what about the absolute value
of three the number three is also three
units away from zero the absolute value
of three will also equal three the
absolute value of minus 29 will be 29
the absolute value of minus 120 will
equal 120 and so on but now I want you
to pause the video for a bit and think
about one real-life application of
absolute value just one if you have not
thought about it before it's okay
most haven't let's say you're based in
Kansas you have New York 1,500 miles to
the east and California 1,500 miles to
the west one day you decide to leave
your friend in New York you leave in the
morning and after having covered around
400 miles you get a football you stop
your car and answer the call you've been
caught to Mountain View California for
an important meeting you decide to rush
towards California it all goes well you
finish your meeting in California and
then you're on your way back home after
covering around 600 miles you decide to
stop for lunch and then you start
wondering about two things first how far
away from home are you placed which
means how far are you from Kansas and
second what's the total distance you've
covered yes how much distance have you
covered in traveling back and forth
let's note down the sequence of events
assuming your home as the reference
point first you traveled 400 miles to
the east
this distance is 400 miles and then from
this point you travel to California what
would be the distance from this point to
California it would be this distance
Plus this distance that would be 400
plus 1500 one
thousand nine hundred miles towards West
and from California you traveled six
hundred miles to the east this distance
is 400 miles this entire distance is
1,900 miles and this distance is 600
miles let's talk about the first
question that came to your mind where
are you in relative to Kansas to
understand that answer think of this as
a number line a number line in which
east is positive and West is negative
400 miles to the east will be positive
four hundred then 1900 miles to the west
would be negative 1900 and 600 miles to
the east would be positive 600 what
would these numbers add up to East is
positive so we write 400 as West is
negative we subtract 1900 and then at
600 again as it's in the positive
direction 400 minus 1900 600 will give
us minus 900 what does - mean in this
particular example it's West so your
relative position will be 900 miles to
the west of Kansas relative position
needs to include the direction I cannot
say that your relative position from
Kansas is just 900 miles because it
could mean 900 miles to the east also so
your relative position from your home is
900 miles to the west the second thing
you were wondering about was the total
distance you have traveled how would you
find the total distance you traveled I
want you to pause the video and work
through this yes
to find the total distance you covered
you would ignore the direction you
traveled 400 miles up to this point then
1,900 miles to California and 600 miles
to this point the total distance would
equal 400 plus 1000 900 plus 600 which
is equal to 2,900 miles wait a moment
what exactly did we do here what we did
here unknowingly was that we found the
absolute value of each number yes we
ignored the sign and simply added the
three numbers so yes a car's odometer
uses the absolute value concept